well lawmakers in California haven't
gotten around to fixing the state's
infrastructure its housing crisis its
homelessness it's vanishing middle class
but they are at the forefront of another
fight rewriting grammar last week the
chair of the state Senate Judiciary
Committee announced that only
gender-neutral pronouns would be
permitted on her a rather their
committee so that we are using what my
Grammatik Gromit teacher would have had
a heart attack over we are using the
phrase they my grammar teachers long
gone and I won't be hearing from her and
if any of you from them exactly from
they Jason Nichols is professor of
african-american studies at University
of Maryland a frequent guest on this
show they join us now I assume you is
still loud so it's good to see you I
just I'm really struck as a function of
human nature but the left is especially
susceptible to it that any dumb trend
that comes along is accepted immediately
and mindlessly by people who should
loggerheads have a very specific you may
disagree with them but like they're
calling for the election of a specific
person but like all the dumb people
decided one day like pronouns are bad
and then we just sort of go along with
it why Dan Tucker I don't think they're
what they're saying is pronouns are bad
he's saying that you should be referred
to the way that you choose to be
referred to so someone who is a man who
identifies as a man yes we can call that
person he someone who identifies as a
woman that person can be she with a
person who is gender non-binary they can
be they or shim or shear or whatever
prone affects you so in general I kind
of agree I call people whatever they
want to be called you married you change
your name I call you by the name exact
whatever I think that's your right and
and out of respect I I go along with it
that's not what they're saying they're
saying that you're not allowed to use
gendered pronouns that's very different
yeah and and I and I actually find that
problematic I believe that people should
have the opportunity to choose what they
want to be called I mean
that's the way you know there's a
problem here this is the kinases
California so you've got more than ten
million people in California speak
Spanish at home right Spanish is a
gendered language that means it is
structurally transphobic will they allow
Spanish to be spoken again a gendered
language in the committee room well
there are people at least in the United
States who are you know there's Latino
latina and Latin X so they're trying to
make it a little but that that's in
English I mean that's how English
speakers describe it but there's no
effort to impose these ludicrous rules
on Spanish and by the way why not call
California California's
I mean if we're really kind of remaining
consistent here yeah well I think
California is the name of a place in
California can't choose in does it
strike you again I think we agree that
if you say you know I'd really like you
to call me this out of politeness and
decency which I sincerely believe in I
will okay but they're forcing people to
say something stupid shouldn't that be
the point where the rest of us say I'm
not policy the problem is that you're
calling that stupid and I don't I don't
think it's stupid to say I mean there
were people many years ago who said his
name was Cassius Clay we're not gonna
call him Mohammed I'll leave that stupid
and to me it's like know whatever you
want to be called whatever you choose
from calling Cassius Clay Muhammad Ali
because he wants to be called he's not
this is for this is a command that
requires people to refer to others who
have not asked to be called this by a
plural pronoun when it's a singular
person right it's grammatically
incorrect it's awkward it's dumb it
doesn't serve the interest of anybody
and it applies to all of us but
everyone's too afraid to call it what it
is first of all language language is
living and breathing it changes it
shifts if you listen to how people talk
in the 1920s they don't talk how they
they don't speak English the same way
they speak English today so I mean but
it
Organic process that's not because some
terrified little bureaucrat decrees that
you must say this on piano hey we're an
agreement about decreeing that you have
to speak one way or or use a pro a
particular pronoun for everyone
I don't like mandating exactly so we're
Nagrand so then let's just assess like
the response why we both agree with this
why don't both of us next time we hear
the say you know what no I'm not playing
along with your fantasy like leave me
alone please well no I mean look afraid
to do that I think my that no I'm not
afraid if I were there I would say well
I prefer he but you know I will call
someone who wants to be called they
shamshir whatever pronoun you cheat here
yeah that's another one but not quite as
popular but if you want to if you want
to call be called something yeah okay
look I agree I just don't think that we
ought to be coercive but they always get
coercive don't think yeah and I think
that that is problematic okay the the
fire of freedom burns brightly in your
heart and I appreciate professor great
to see you thanks Tucker always fun